>> Greg: WILL HE GIVE UP HIS
PIPE FOR A FEMININE WIPE?
WILL THE GUY WHO SAID I AM WHAT
I AM NOW ONLY ANSWER TO MADAME?
THE 93-YEAR-OLD COMIC STRIP
POPEYE'S GETTING A MAKEOVER
THANKS TO A BUSYBODY CARTOONIST
WHO PROMISES IF YOU ARE STRAIGHT
CHARACTERS AND MORE ETHNIC
DIVERSITY.
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT FANS OF A
93-YEAR-OLD COMIC STRIP WANT.
A NONBINARY PLUTO.
ARTIST RANDOL MILL HOLLAND
EXPLAINS I WANT TO BRING IN MORE
CHARACTERS WHO AREN'T
HETEROSEXUAL -- I LOVE THIS SO
MUCH.
I DON'T LIVE IN THAT STRAIGHT
WHITE WORLD AND I DON'T THINK A
LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE DO EITHER,
SO BRAVE.
ACCORDING, POPEYE MIGHT HAVE ONE
ADDRESS ONCE BY TODAY'S
DEFINITION, POPEYE IS GENDER
FLUID TO.
IF YOU WEAR A DRESS, THAT IS
GENDER FLUID, SOMEONE HAD BETTER
TELL THOSE GUYS IN KILTS.
THAT'S ADDRESS.
MANY POPEYE STORIES FEATURED HIM
FIRING DOWN A CAN OF SPINACH,
PUMMELING PLUTO AFTER HE TRIED
TO MAKE A MOVE ON OLIVE OYL WHO
IS AN ATTRACTIVE, I'M OKAY WITH
SAYING THAT.
BUT HE SAYS I WANT TO GET AWAY
FROM THAT, I SEE THESE
CHARACTERS AS PEOPLE WHO ARE
SOMETIMES MEAN TO ONE ANOTHER
BUT WHO ALSO CARE ABOUT EACH
OTHER.
THAT DOESN'T SOUND EXCITING AT
ALL.
I DON'T WATCH ROADRUNNER
CARTOONS TO SEE HIM CARING ABOUT
WILE E. COYOTE, I WATCH TO SEE
AMAZING NEW PRODUCTS FROM THE
ACNE CORPORATION.
ENTERTAINMENT IS NO LONGER MEANT
TO ENTERTAIN ONLY TILL LET
MEDIOCRITIES LIKE RANDALL SOUND
IMPORTANT.
MAY BE POPEYE DOES NEED TO
CHANGE.
PEOPLE FORGET WITH THOSE OLD
CARTOONS WERE LIKE -- REMEMBER
THIS ONE?
>> POPEYE, TELL YOUR NOSY BROAD
TO BE THAT.
>> HOW DARE YOU SPEAK TO ME LIKE
THAT!
>> WHY DON'T YOU TAKE THIS
SPINACH BACK TO THE KITCHEN
WHERE YOU BELONG.
>> I WANT TO TRY SOME!
♪ ♪
>> WHAT A STUPID [BLEEP].
>> I FINALLY HAD THE ENERGY TO
COOK, CLEAN, AND DO HOUSE CHORES
ALL DAY!
THE ONLY THING A WOMAN IS GOOD
FOR!
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THOSE WERE THE GOOD
OLD DAYS IS WHAT A SEXIST WOULD
SAY.
THIS IS RIGHT UP YOUR ALLEY FOR
YOUR BOOK, I'M ASSUMING THIS IS
REAL, RIGHT?
UNLESS THIS GUY IS A MASTER
TROLL AND HE'S LAMPOONING THE
WOKE BECAUSE HE'S USING ALL THE
RIGHT LINGO BUT I'M GOING TO
ASSUME IT'S REAL, THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT YOUR BOOK IS
FOCUSING ON, THEY ARE APPLYING
POLITICAL OR IDEOLOGICAL THINGS
TO STUFF THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
FUN.
>> THIS ACTUALLY COULD JUST BE
FOR US.
A COMMERCIAL DECISION THAT MAKES
SENSE, HOW ELSE IS POPEYE GOING
TO BE REMOTELY RELEVANT UNLESS
IT CAPTURES -- THERE IS A MORAL
PHILOSOPHY, A FRAMEWORK BEING
APPLIED HERE AND YOU'RE SEEING
IT BEING APPLIED IN DISNEY AND I
HAVE A DOZEN OTHER ENTERTAINING
COMPANIES WHERE YOU CAN PRODUCE
ENTERTAINMENT ANYMORE, IT HAS TO
HAVE A SOCIAL VALUE.
IT HAS TO BE GRANDER AND SERVE
THIS PURPOSE.
EVEN IF IT IS STILTED AND MAKES
FOR BAD ART WE HAVE TO BLUDGEON
YOU WITH THIS DIDACTIC NARRATIVE
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT VERY CAPABLE
OF CATCHING A SUBTLE NARRATIVE.
>> A MORAL, A LESSON.
>> Greg: DON'T SPREAD YOUR
IGNORANCE AROUND LIKE MANURE,
CONTINUE.
>> I'M DONE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'M UPSET BECAUSE YOU SAID
OLIVE OYL WASN'T ATTRACTIVE AND
SHE AND I HAVE THE EXACT SAME
BODY.
INSULTS MY ONE REPRESENTATION OF
MY BODY IN THE MEDIA.
>> Greg: MAYBE YOU COULD BE
HER LOVER IN THE NEW POPEYE.
>> I WOULD DO ANYTHING IF THEY
CALLED ME.
>> Greg: DO YOU BELIEVE IT'S?
>> I GUESS.
THE THING ABOUT THIS IS WHEN
IT'S CONTRIVED IT TENDS TO FEEL
CONTRIVED.
I DIDN'T KNOW POPEYE WAS STILL
DOING STUFF.
THEY PROBABLY ARE RUNNING OUT OF
IDEAS BECAUSE 93 YEARS IS A LONG
TIME.
MAYBE THAT WAS WHY THEY REALLY
WANTED TO DO IT TO.
WE HAVE DONE EVERYTHING ELSE,
NOW HE'S NONBINARY.
THAT COULD GIVE ANOTHER 93
YEARS.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE BIGGER
BICEPS THAN POPEYE BUT HE HAS
HUGE FOREARMS.
HIS FOREARMS ARE MASSIVE.
WHY ARE HIS FOREARMS SO BIG?
>> I THOUGHT HIS FOREARMS LOOK
NORMAL BUT WHATEVER.
THE FACT THAT HIM BEING DEFORMED
IN THE FACE AND ARMS WASN'T
ENOUGH FOR INCLUSION.
I WONDER WHAT THE NEW CHANGE IN
CHARACTERS, WHAT COLOR BLUTO IS
GOING TO BE.
I WONDER IF HE'S GOING TO END UP
BLACK.
I'M JUST SPITTING IT OUT THERE,
PAY -- THESE ARE CARTOONS.
BUGS BUNNY HAD NO PROBLEM
PUTTING A DRESS ON AND LIPSTICK
AND TRICKING ELMER TO FALL IN
LOVE WITH HIM AND 30 SECONDS.
AND WE ALL LAUGHED AND CHEERED
IT ON AS CHILDREN.
>> Greg: I REMEMBER BEING
SOMEWHAT ATTRACTED WHEN HE WAS
CROSS-DRESSING.
>> THE ONLY ONE WHO NEVER FELL
FOR IT WAS THE ANGRY BLACK DUCK,
THAT'S THE ONLY THING THEY GOT
RIGHT.
HE WOULD HATE ON IT.
>> WE WOULD LABEL YOUR
QUESTIONING.
>> Greg: I WOULD CHOOSE
BUGS BUNNY IN DRAG OVER
JESSICA RABBIT.
>> REALLY?
>> YOU LOST ME THERE.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
>> JUST WHEN YOU THINK THERE IS
NO WAY THEY ARE ACTUALLY GOING
TO DEFEND SOMETHING WOULD PUSH
IT FURTHER.
THE DISNEY THING WHEN YOU HAD
THAT ZOOM CALL THAT CAME OUT AND
THE HEAD OF CONTENT IT WASN'T A
RANDOM PERSON AT DISNEY WHO SAID
WE NEED MORE PANSEXUAL
CHARACTERS AND THIS WAS FOR
CARTOONS.
THE BLUE CHECK MAFIA ONLINE SAID
HOW COULD YOU NOT KNOW WHAT IT
IS?
THEN YOU SAY OMNI, WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN?
THEY LOOK FOR THE NEXT THING.
YOU CAN ALWAYS SAY WHERE IS THE
REPRESENTATION OF AND MAKE
SOMETHING UP AND THE LEFT WILL
FREAK OUT ABOUT IT.
YOU COME UP WITH SOMETHING,
YOU'RE JUST LIKE HONESTLY NOT
ENOUGH VEGAN ASTRONAUTS WHO ARE
OPPRESSED AND THEY WILL ALL OF A
SUDDEN SAY WE NEED TO PUT MORE
OF THOSE IN OUR CONTENT.
IF THEY EXCLUDE ANYBODY THE
HOUSE OF CARDS STARTS TO FALL
DOWN.
IF THEY EVER SAY LGBTQ, WHAT
ABOUT THE IA PLUS.
THEY SAY I'M SORRY, THEY DON'T
SAY IT'S THE LONGEST IN THE
HISTORY OF ACRONYMS, IT'S GOTTEN
ABSURD.
>> Greg: I WONDER IF THIS IS
GOING TO COME OUT TO AN
ELABORATE RUSE.
IT'S POPEYE THE SAILOR MAN,
DON'T TURN THEM INTO A BIRTHING
PERSON.
ALTHOUGH BHUTTO COULD IDENTIFY
AS A TRANS-FEMALE AND COMPETE IN
MAIL CARTOON SPORTS.
WE GOT TO MOVE ON, ENOUGH OF